ein jahr später sind die wassermassen
verschwunden und mit ihnen die erste
aufbau euphorie geblieben ist im aartal
vor allem ernüchterung
ja ist traurig langsam alles traurig
langsam man sieht irgendwie den
politischen willen nicht dass man hier
zügig fertig wird sieht einfach
irgendwie hat man den stillstand hier
erreicht
sebastian kress hat das drama im aartal
nur knapp überlebt bis unter die decke
stand das wasser in seinem restaurant
vor einem jahr folgte auf die flutwelle
eine welle der solidarität aus der
ganzen republik strömten politiker ins
katastrophengebiet wo sebastian klaas
kam im oktober sogar der bundespräsident
wir werden euch nicht vergessen das war
das versprechen aus den tagen der flut
ein versprechen das wir einhalten müssen
versprochen wurde den betroffenen auch
eine schnelle aufarbeitung der
katastrophe
doch bei eben dieser aufarbeitung schien
für die politik 1 erstaunlich schnell
fest zu stehen
das wesen von katastrophen ist dass sie
nicht vorhersehbar sind das wesen von
naturkatastrophen ist dass sie es
rechtlich vorhersehbar sind was wir
jetzt erlebt haben das hat eine
dimension die wir noch nirgends erlebt
haben es war keine situation die
beschrieben hat das was wir am schluss
heute wissen dabei wussten experten
schon früh das auf die region etwas
zukommt
am 10 juli vier tage vor der flut warnt
das europäische flugbahn system efas vor
überschwemmungen in der region am 12
juli um 11 59 warnt auch der deutsche
wetterdienst vor ergiebigem dauerregen
das ifas ruft am selben tag zwei tage
vor der flut für die a die höchste
warnstufe aus
hannah clark hat das europäische flut
warnsystem mit aufgebaut wurde als
expertin vor die untersuchungsausschüsse
in düsseldorf und mainz geladen wie
bewertet sie den umgang mit den
warnungen
es ist nicht richtig dass wir diese flut
nicht vorhersagen konnten wir haben
mehrere tage vorher gesehen dass etwas
ernstes passieren wird angesichts der
vielen menschen die gestorben sind sind
definitiv informationen nicht zu denen
gelangt die sie gebraucht haben
dort wo die versäumnisse der flut
aufgeklärt werden sollen mag diese
kritik nicht jeder hören wir haben immer
mal auch eine extrem aussage von von
zeuginnen und zeugen es gibt im
nachhinein auch viele die möglicherweise
alles gewusst haben aber die
verantwortlichen vor ort sagen unisono
wir sind von dieser dimension überrascht
worden das heißt man kann eigentlich
grundsätzlich gar nichts ändern doch man
kann es ändern wir wissen ja auch dass
die
hochwasservorhersage die höchste
warnstufe am späten nachmittag
ausgerufen war so und das ist der
zeitpunkt wo es dann auch belastbar wird
dabei gab es belastbare warnungen schon
deutlich früher
11 uhr das landesamt für umwelt spricht
die zweithöchste warnstufe für die aus
um 11.15 wird ein höchststand berechnet
drei meter und 30 um 15 uhr 26 wird die
prognose hochgeschraubt auf fünf meter
19 anderthalb meter höher als beim
letzten hochwasser
2016 trotz allem verschickt das
umweltministerium von einem spiegel um
16 uhr 43 eine pressemitteilung es drohe
kein extrem hochwasser eine fatale
fehleinschätzung
um 17 uhr 17 wird die höchste
hochwassergefährdung ausgerufen pegel
und prognosen steigen unaufhörlich 20
uhr 45 die a steht bei 5 meter 75 eine
letzte prognose wird veröffentlicht
sechs meter 92 um 21 uhr fallen die
messsysteme aus bis heute ist nicht klar
wie hoch die in dieser nacht gestiegen
ist fünf stunden später gegen 2 uhr
nachts sterben zwölf menschen im
flussabwärts gelegenen sind sich es in
zwölf von insgesamt
134 todesopfern an der
daniel wrobel begleitet den
aufarbeitungsprozess an der von anfang
an ist journalist bei einer lokalzeitung
schon wenige tage nach der flut haben
wir mit ihm gesprochen und schon damals
hatte daniel wrobel eine klare forderung
irgendeiner muss dafür gerade stehen und
uns da bei dem aufbau aktiv treffen ein
jahr später sitzt daniel wrobel noch am
selben platz und die frage ist noch
immer die gleiche hat jemand
verantwortung übernommen echte
politische verantwortung wie man sich
das wünschen würde kann ich bisher nicht
so registrieren den rücktritt den wir
beispielsweise von frau spiegel hatten
das wort es ging ja gar nicht darum
irgend welchen ausmaß das die flut jetzt
zugeschlagen hat es ging dabei um
urlaube es ging um gender sternchen um
verantwortungs zuweisungen das sind
alles sachen die sind jetzt bei mir
hängen geblieben aber nicht
wir haben hier konkret in der nacht vom
15 auf den 15 juli jetzt falsch reagiert
auch in nordrhein westfalen warten die
menschen darauf dass jemand
verantwortung übernimmt auch im
düsseldorfer landtag arbeitet ein
untersuchungsausschuss konsequenzen aus
den geschehnissen auch hier mangelware
ich habe allergrößtes verständnis dafür
dass die betroffenen menschen in der
region die auch geschädigte sind eine
andere erwartung haben die wollen wissen
wer trägt eigentlich die verantwortung
für das was geschehen ist bisher ist der
untersuchungsausschuss bei der frage
nach der verantwortung nicht weit
gekommen woran das liegt ist klar
der umstand der landtagswahl hat das
gemeinsame arbeiten an den zielen die
der parlamentarische
untersuchungsausschuss hat nämlich auch
den blick nach vorne zu richten und für
verbesserungen zu sorgen nicht gerade
beflügelt ein jahr ist sie her die
größte flutkatastrophe in deutschland
seit jahrzehnten
186 todesopfer doch die reden mancher
politiker klingen als könne es fast so
weitergehen wie bisher
das möglicherweise auch noch mal
geschaut werden muss wie der
katastrophenschutz in anderer form auch
noch unterstützt um beim nächsten mal
noch besser vorbereitet zu sein für die
betroffenen im aartal muss das seltsam
zynisch klingen sebastian klaas hat
jedenfalls nicht das gefühl dass die
politik ihre versprechen aus den tagen
der flut halten wird
wir haben die besten ecken gezeigt
bekommen wo ich wieder gut aussieht dann
multimedial schön verpackt und dann sind
die wieder heimgefahren und dann ist da
das programm für die zu ende also das
gefühl hat man ganz einfach
und so stehen viele menschen im aartal
auch ein jahr nach der flut vor den
trümmern ihrer existenz
dass jemand für fehler verantwortung
übernimmt darauf warten sie bis heute
vergeblich